>>As part of the Davos Debates, I've been
asked as the UN International
Development Section of the United Kingdom
why we attach such importance
to education and what kind of benefits education
brings beyond
education itself.
All of the evidence that we've studied from
countries right around the
world indicates, for example, if you educate
a young girl, she will
marry later; she'll get pregnant later.
She'll be more likely to be employed in the
formal sector rather than
the informal sector of the economy.
She will have better health because she'll
be better aware and better
able to take care of herself.
That's why we believe there are huge benefits
beyond simply education.
And that's why we're making record levels
of investments to support in
countries their education systems.
We know what to do.
We know which trained teachers to build schools,
to provide classrooms.
That's why when we helped abolish user fees
in countries like Kenya,
Uganda and [INAUDIBLE] literally hundreds
of thousands of poor children
turned up to school on Monday morning.
Best way to work is changing lives, but also
I believe it can change
the future of those countries.